so I have a rational expression here and
what my goal is is to simplify it but
while I simplify it I want to make the
simplified expression be algebraically
equivalent so if there are certain
x-values that would make this thing
undefined that I have to restrict my
simplified expression by those X values
so you could pause this video and take a
go at it and then we'll do it together
all right so let's just think real quick
what would what X values would make this
expression undefined well it's not
defined if we try to divide by zero so
if x is 0 14 times 0 is 0 it's going to
be undefined and so we could say we
could say this is we could say X does
not cannot be equal to 0 for any other X
we can evaluate this expression now
let's actually try to simplify it so
when you look at the numerator in the
denominator every term we see is
divisible by X and every term is
divisible by 7 so it looks like we can
factor 7 X out of the numerator and a 7
X out of the denominator so the
numerator we can rewrite as 7 x times if
you factor 7 x out of 14 x squared
you're going to be left with the 2x and
then you factor a 7 X out of 7 X you're
going to be left with a 1 and one way to
think about it is we did the distribute
distributive property in Reverse if you
do it again 7x times 2x is 14x squared
7x times 1 is 7x
all right and now let's factor 7x out of
the denominator so 14x could be
re-written as 7 x times 2 times 2 and
remember I want to keep this
algebraically equivalent so I want to
keep the constraint that X cannot be
equal to 0 and so we divide the
numerator and the denominator by 7x or
you one way to think well you could've
I'd 7x by 7x and just get 1 and we are
left with 2x plus 1 over 2 now this was
the original expression X could take on
any value but what if we want it to be
algebraically equivalent to our original
expression it has to have the same
constraints on it so we're going to have
to say X X does not equal 0 and this is
a real it's a very subtle but really
important thing for example if you
find a function by this right over here
the domain of the function could not
include zero and so if you simplified
how you how you define that function to
this if you want that function to be the
same it needs to have the same domain
has to be defined for the same inputs
and so that's why we're putting the
exact same constraints for them to be
equivalent if you got rid of this
constraint these these two would be
equivalent everywhere except for x
equals zero this one would have been
defined for x equals zero this one would
not have and so they wouldn't been
algebraically equivalent
this makes them algebraically equivalent
and of course you could write this in
different ways you could divide each of
these terms by two if you like so you
could divide 2x by two and get X and
then divide one by 2 and get 1/2 but
once again we would want to keep the X
cannot be equal to zero let's do another
one of these so it's a slightly hairier
expression but let's do the same drill
and see if we could simplify it but as
we simplify we really want to be
conscientious of of restricting the Z's
here so that we get an algebraically
equivalent expression so let's think
about where this is undefined we could
think about where it's undefined by
factoring the denominator here and
actually let me just so this is going to
be equal to actually let me just let me
just do the first step where I could see
well what's a common factor in the
numerator in the denominator every term
here is divided by Z squared and every
term is also divided by 17 so it looks
like 17 Z squared can be factored out so
17 Z squared can be factored out of the
numerator and then we would be left with
you factor out a 17 Z squared out of 17
Z to the third and you're going to be
left with just a Z 17 Z squared you
factor 17 Z squared out of that you're
going to be left with just a 1 and once
again you can you can distribute the 17
Z squared multiply it times Z you get 17
C to the third 17 Z squared times 1 is
17 Z squared alright all of that is
going to be over we want to factor out a
17 Z squared out of the denominator 17 Z
squared times
and so 34 is Z to the third divided by
17 Z squared 34 divided by 17 is 2 and
as Z to the 3rd divided by Z squared is
Z and then we have minus 51 divided by
17 is 3 and Z squared divided by Z
squared is just 1 so we'll just leave it
like that and so over here it becomes a
little bit clearer of well what how
we're going to simplify it we're just
going to divide 17 Z squared by 17 Z
squared but let's be careful to restrict
the domain here so we can tell if Z is
equal to 0 then this then 17 Z squared
is going to be equal to 0 to make the
denominator equal to 0 and we could see
that even looking here so we could say Z
cannot be equal to 0 and what else
Z cannot be equal to whatever makes this
2 Z minus 3 equals 0
so let's think about what makes 2 Z
minus 3 equal to 0 2 Z minus 3 is equal
to 0 you can add 3 to both sides and you
would get 2 Z is equal to 3 divide both
sides by 2
and you would get Z is equal to 3 halves
so Z cannot be equal to 0 and Z cannot
be equal to 3 halves so that's how we're
going to restrict our domain but now
let's simplify so if we simplify it
these two cancel out and we are going to
be left with we're going to be left with
Z plus 1 over 2 Z minus 3 and we want to
keep that constraint Z Z cannot be equal
to 0 and actually this second constraint
is redundant because we still have the 2
Z minus 3 here someone were to just look
at this expression like well the
denominator can't be equal to 0 and so Z
cannot be equal to three-halves so this
is still if we just left it the way it
is if we don't have to rewrite this that
would be redundant since looking at this
expression it's clearly not defined for
Z equals 3 halves so there you go if
someone asks you for what values is this
expression not defined well then you
could you would also include that
actually let me just write it doesn't
hurt to be redundant Z does not equal
three halves but this this constraint
right here is really important because
it's not obvious by looking at this
expression this expression by itself
would be defined for Z equals zero but
if we wanted to be algebraically
equivalent to this one in that one it
has to be constrained in the same in the
same way